[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jacques mézard le ministre de
l'agriculture et de l'alimentation est
l'invité de l'épreuve de vérité bonsoir
monsieur le ministre
et merci d'être avec nous à ce
rendez-vous de public sénat avec les
échos radio classique et agence france
presse et vous répondrez à trois grandes
questions au cours de cette émission
questions que viendront vous posez tour
à tour jean francis pécresse lucile
malandain et au rayonnement de fini
d'abord comment sauver l'agriculture
française puisque c'est bien cela
l'enjeu pour vous aujourd'hui enfin
jouer vous le gouvernement comme
emmanuel macron d'ailleurs à quitte ou
double à l'occasion des élections
législatives et puis dans la troisième
partie
on vous interrogera sur vous votre
parcours et puis on vous demandera
également si vous êtes soluble à 100%
dans le maquereau nice aujourd'hui car
on pense notamment à certaines de vos
prises de position et lente qui ont
marqué votre engagement politique
jacques mézard je pense à la laïcité au
cumul des mandats ou encore à la
moralisation de la vie politique mais
d'abord une première question
d'actualité
[Musique]
le monstrueux attentats de manchester la
nuit dernière suscite bien sûr une
nouvelle indignation dans le monde
entier emmanuel macron a dit son effroi
sa consternation je me souviens de vos
interventions jacques mézard y compris
d'ailleurs à la tribune du congrès en
tant que président du groupe rdse au
sénat sur le terrorisme et au delà de la
compassion comment est-ce que là ce soir
vous avez envie de réagir
tu es toujours difficile de réagir face
à l'horreur et là l'horreur et non c'est
monstrueux parce que s'attaquer à des
innocents c'est toujours terrible
s'attaquer à des enfants ça en plus et
une connotation qui est encore plus
horrible s'il pouvait y avoir des degrés
dans l'horreur et et nous voyons là que
le terrorisme frappe tous les pays
frappent régulièrement et que l'enjeu
qui auxquels nous sommes confrontés
c'est de le réduire et pour le réduire
il n'y a qu'une solution c'est la
coopération internationale
nous le savons tous sachant que c'est
une
ce qui est extrêmement difficile assure
alors vous dites renforcer la
coopération internationale notamment en
europe c'est ce que préconise d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui même le chef de l'état mais
il ya également le combat
jacques mézard à l'intérieur de nos
frontières comment faire face à la
radicalisation d'une partie de notre
jeunesse qui programment désormais la
mort d'autres jeunes
nous avons vu au cours de ces dernières
années la diffusion de ces d'une
idéologie de destruction qui a été il
faut bien le dire aussi facilitée par ce
qui se passe c'est ce qui s'est passé au
moyen-orient qui a été facilité aussi
par les réseaux sociaux par les nouveaux
modes de transmission de la
communication c'est une c'est une
réalité
là je pense d'ailleurs que nous serons
dans l'obligation de travailler sur ces
domaines là un avantage est que nous
avons une part de responsabilité nous la
société dans son ensemble dans ses
dérives des djihadistes nés sur notre
sol cette idée a été émise dans la
campagne par emmanuel macron ou est-ce
qu'il faut s'interroger sur notre
responsabilité bien sûr qu'il ya une
responsabilité collective stabilité
internationale parce qu'on s'est quand
même qu'un certain nombre d'actions en
tout cas c'est ma position et je l'ait
déjà énoncé à la tribune du sénat
certaines actions les pays occidentaux
au moyen-orient qui n'ont pas facilité
les choses et dont on peut dire ce qui
s'est passé en irak ce qui s'est passé
ensuite en libye par exemple je ne pense
pas que ça ait pas eu peur que ça a été
très positive à part avant le chef de
l'état qui n'était pas encore et
évoquerait des difficultés d'intégration
les ratés des relations qui peuvent
déboucher sur ce genre de comportement
bien sûr qu'il ya des ratés de
l'intégration et que c'est une
responsabilité collective bon si nous ne
sommes pas capables nous de considérer
que nous avons une part de
responsabilité dans la dérive d'une
partie de notre population et de nos
jeunes et dans un certain nombre de
quartiers se seront dans un pas très
réaliste faut-il repousser les
interrogations sur le maintien de l'état
d'urgence je vous pose la question car
vous êtes très sourcilleux sur les
questions de libertés publiques et sur
le pouvoir de la justice
aujourd'hui j'ai toujours voté l'état
d'urgence en considérant
que l'état d'urgence ne devait pas être
définitif bon la difficulté la belgique
le combat et sera long contre la
barbarie des lacs c'est à dire que si
vous voulez l'état d'urgence c'est
facile de le mettre en place au niveau
législatif
c'est beaucoup plus difficile de
l'arrêter parce que on a fait je vous
rappelle qu'en france nous avons failli
le gouvernement de l'époque a failli
arrêter la veille de l'attentât de nice
ban est ce que l'état d'urgence
aujourd'hui suffi à régler les problèmes
de terrorisme certainement pas bons
qu'est ce qu'il ya dans l'état d'urgence
de particulier c'est que ça facilite les
perquisitions administrative que ça
facilite certaines assignation à
résidence
je crois qu'aujourd'hui dans la
situation dans laquelle nous sommes
en tout cas ça mérite réflexion au
niveau de ce nouveau gouvernement pour
voir comment on fait évoluer les choses
comment faire évoluer les choses
éventuellement la suite de l'épreuve de
vérité tout de suite jacques mézard avec
jean francis pécresse le directeur de la
rédaction de radio classique qui nous
rejoint
[Musique]
bonsoir jean pons par jacques mézard
long soir question simple pour commencer
vous découvrez un monde agricole en
crise comment est ce que vous comptez
répondre à cette crise qui est à la fois
une créance de compétitivité et une
crise conjoncturelle liée à de mauvaises
conditions climatiques
d'abord cher monsieur je ne découvre pas
le monde agricole et je ne découvre
malgré tout le monde agricole en crise
il n'y avait rien de désagréable
ces jeux je suis et le parlementaire
d'un département rural mondiale quels
sont vos urgences pour vous aujourd'hui
face à ce danger de mort de
l'agriculture française comme une
certaine agricoles de côté
donc je n'ai je pas autant je suis
convaincu de la situation de crise de la
désespérance d'un certain nombre
d'agriculteurs d'un nombre important
d'agriculteurs et quand je connais les
suicides qui existe dans l'es9 agricole
oui l éleveur nous élevons peut pas être
insensible à ce qui se passe bon ceci
étant l'agriculture française n'est pas
en situation de mort
elle est en situation problématique dans
un certain nombre de dossiers quelles
sont mes priorités priorité il ya les
paiements la patte de la pac sont en
retard qui sont en retard et la première
j'aurais fait la première un vrai
problème et ce pour l'agriculture bio
qui sont aussi beaucoup portent harkis
qui rappellent ceux de 2015 on part on
parle vous vous avez eu des vents et
qu'est-ce que vous plaît là la première
chose la première question que j'ai
posée à l'administration du ministère
c'est celle là il y à des retards
on peut pas se contenter de cette
situation
donc nous avons déjà travaillé un
certain nombre de réponses vont être
données rapidement sur le premier pilier
avec des paiements d'ici
30 juin sur li chn
aussi on va aller relativement vite et
il reste six chn pour lui on était ce
nécessaire d indemnité compensatrice des
handicaps naturels sur la question vous
poser et à biot effectivement 2015 n'a
pas encore été payé
donc j'ai demandé je suis knees
l'agriculture depuis moins d'une semaine
j'ai demandé ils sont les régions
maintenant oui alors ces aides alors
qu'à leurs yeux ce que je constate
contraindre à aller un petit peu plus
vite que ce que je constate c'est qu'il
y a un problème d'articulation entre
l'administration d'état et puis les
régions avec une diversité dans la
manière d'appréhender les dossiers par
les conseils régionaux donc ce que je
vais faire c'est prendre contact avec
l'association des régions de france pour
que nous ayons une discussion et pour
voir quelles sont les difficultés
auxquelles ils sont confrontés et
comment on peut mieux coordonner nos
répondants mais il faut c'est une
c'est une vraie préoccupation et c'est
une préoccupation d'autant plus
importante que je considère que ce qui a
été fait j'ai pas toujours été tendre
avec le quinquennat précédent mais en ce
qui concerne la négociation de la pac
pense que en particulier pour les
éleveurs il y avait eu il y avait eu de
bons résultats mais ses résultats sont
gâchées par le fait que la plaie les
paiements l'application non pas n'a pas
été réalisé dans deux dans le canton
quel rôle il va falloir leur thune
priori acte d'autorité
dernière question rapide est ce que le
plan de 5 milliards d'euros
d'investissements qui avait été promis
par emmanuel macron dans sa campagne
électorale
est-ce qu'il est toujours d'actualité
bien sûr vous savez le président de la
république
il tient à exécuter le programme qu'il a
soumis aux français ce qui changera
peut-être du passé bon alors une
dernière question vous vous avez annoncé
une loi pour alléger l'énorme 1 qui
pèsent sur l'agriculture ce que vous
allez ya un risque d'exploser de deux
conflits là avec votre collègue nicolas
hulot aussi un relâchement par exemple
sur les normes environnementales
écoutez moi je n'aborde pas le travail
du gouvernement dans le conflit
mais nicolas n'en ont pas mais nicolas
hulot est un homme intelligent il l'a
d'ailleurs montré dans les discussions a
eu avec d'autres responsabilités il ya
quelques mois avec la fédération
nationale bovine un jeu je vais dans ce
gouvernement
j'ai accepté d'y être pour aller dans un
travail de concertation et pour faire
avancer les choses très bien le
gouvernement va en parler dans un
instant merci selon francis avec lucile
malandain qui nous rejoint pour la
deuxième partie est la deuxième grande
question donc de cette émission
l'épreuve de vérité
l'épreuve de vérité avec les filles
bonsoir laisser mon père michel bonsoir
monsieur bizarre bonsoir
alors la question concerne les
législatives
justement le gouvernement et le
président de la république vous ne jouez
pas quitte ou double aux législatives
qui vont avoir lieu le 11 et 18 juin
est ce qu'il ya une majorité possible
pour emmanuel macron et pour pouvoir
gouverner côté la vie démocratique n'est
pas un jeu le président de la république
il a été élu avec un programme et nous
sommes dans une situation depuis le
quinquennat et l'inversion des
calendriers ou législatifs sont quelques
semaines après les présidentielles
là aussi je crois au bon sens populaire
sa part et révolutionnaire de croire au
bon sens mais imaginez que nos
concitoyens ne vont pas donner une
majorité au président de la république
pour gouverner je crois que ça ne sera
pas le cas ça ne sera pas le cas parce
que nos concitoyens savent que président
de la république a besoin d'une majorité
pour réaliser le programme qui est le
sien et que si ce n'était pas le cas
une cohabitation en début de quinquennat
nous savons tous que ça ne serait pas
une très bonne chose mais est ce que en
sans parler de cohabitation est ce que
il en marche peut obtenir la majorité
absolue aux législatives
ou est-ce qu'il va pas falloir
travailler avec d autres groupes
politiques au sein de l'assemblée
qui seront pour dire comme des groupes
d'appui qui appuieront plus ou moins le
gouvernement là la question et
diplomatiquement formulée je vous en
félicite
vous pouvez beaucoup plus froid et
directe dans la réponse à 13h une corde
notre objectif c'est d'avoir une
majorité en marche
il y à des candidats provenant de
différentes sensibilités des candidats
aussi provenant de la société civile
bien sûr que ce que nous souhaitons
c'est d'avoir une majorité solide
si les électeurs décident de nous donner
une majorité relative
nous avons la capacité président de la
république a la capacité de rassembler
et de travailler avec ce que vous avez
appelé des groupes dans des puits des
groupes daley et mes groupes d'appui si
ça doit constituer de venir des groupes
frondeurs ça c'est pas possible
d'accord on va écouter pierre et jean
pierre raffarin qui réagit à cette
grande recomposition qui est en cours
jacques mézard et il ne rejette pas a
priori un vote de confiance au
gouvernement et il imagine même voir
naître un nouveau groupe de députés en
les côtes
moi je pense qu'il faut qu'il y ait à
l'assemblée des députés républicains que
j'appellerai les constructif les
constructifs ils devront soutenir les
réformes positives les constructifs ils
devront soutenir la réforme du code du
travail les constructifs ils devront
soutenir les efforts sur la sécurité son
développement du renseignement les
constructif devront corriger quand les
des lois sont mauvaises il faut aller à
l'assemblée nationale avec des gens
constructif ne pas empêcher macron de
faire les bonnes réformes et de corriger
les mauvaises notes à côté je vous savez
j'ai beaucoup de sympathie pour le
premier ministre raffarin il est
tellement constructif un que je ne peux
qu'être heureux de ces déclarations
parce que au delà de l'humour c'est la
démonstration que le message des manuels
macron est entendu dans ce pays que nous
sommes en train de sortir
de blocage politique qui n'ont qui
n'avait plus guère de sens
oui mais alors on voit jean pierre
raffarin parle au nom des républicains
on voit bien qu'à gauche
c'est un petit peu plus compliqué vous
même vous faites partie de la gauche
puisque vous êtes au prg centre gauche
le parti de centre gauche
enfin bon vous êtes quand même plutôt de
ce côté là du chiqué comment comment
est-ce que ça va s'organiser sachant
qu'il ya des candidats de la majorité
présidentielle qui se présente un peu
partout parfois les uns contre les
autres
en tout cinq circonscriptions quelle
organisation de base ce sont ceux qui
sont en marche c'est à dire ceux qui
soutiendront l'action et le programme du
président de la république
quand j le programme il s'agit d'un
certain nombre d'objectifs qui sont qui
ont été affirmés au cours de la campagne
ça ne veut pas dire d'être le doigt sur
la couture du pantalon pendant cinq ans
parce que un parlement qui n'auraient
aucune liberté une majorité qui
n'auraient aucune liberté d'expression
sand en général ça ne se finit pas bien
mais sur des objectifs fondamentaux qui
ont été clairement dégagée par le
président de la république bien sûr que
ça doit fonctionner sans trop délicat et
justement car on parlait de la gauche
bon laquelle alors justement il ya
certains
député sortant ancien ministre
maintenant me myriam el khomri ou alors
marisol touraine qui ont gommé
l'étiquette du parti socialiste qui est
en pleine panique vous le savez ça vous
fait sourire peut-être jacques mézard
qu'est ce que vous pensez de par exemple
marisol touraine qui se présente comme
candidate de la majorité présidentielle
et qui d'ailleurs s'expose à des
sanctions de la commission des conflits
du ps et vous l'encouragez à tenir bon
je ne vais pas je serais hypocrite si je
pleurais sur l'état du parti socialiste
je constate que un certain nombre
d'anciens ministres ou deux députés
sortants socialistes
vu ce qui s'est passé ces dernières
années vu ce qui s'est passé au cours de
ces présidentielle considère que le
programme du nouveau président de la
république d'emmanuel bakr on est un bon
programme est bien certain question un
petit peu différemment au sein du parti
radical de gauche annick girardin joël
giraud sylvia pinel n'ont pas de
candidat dans marche en face d'eux pour
les législatives
concrètement s'ils sont élus bon anniv
gérardin mise à part puisque les
ministres mais s'ils sont élus dans quel
groupe parlementaire vont-ils 6g vont
siéger dans un groupe en marche ont
séché dans un groupe prg et autres
accompagnateurs de la politique
gouvernementale à l'assemblée nationale
je ne doute pas qu'ils siégeront dans le
groupe en marche
ce qui n'exclut pas pour eux de garder
leur sensibilité mais il est nécessaire
à l'assemblée nationale d'avoir un
groupe en marche de manière tout à fait
clair les données je n'ai vraiment pas
de doute sur le fait que les noms que
vous avez cités aileron dans un groupe
en marche et sans hypocrisie là encore
si demain le parti socialiste
disparaissait ou ne pleut riez pas
écoutez la réponse est dans la question
bon dans l'actualité il y à la question
importante vous qu'être très attaché au
travail parlementaire il ya la défense
travail des parlementaires
la question des ordonnances et
ordonnances ton que le président
emmanuel macron compte passer par
ordonnance par exemple du code du
travail les syndicats se sont montrés
déjà assez défiant comment est-ce que
comment est ce que vous prenez ça vous
qui défendez justement le rôle du
parlement et du débat au sein du
parlement
je vais aussi vous répondra clairement
les ordonnances y avoir une loi
d'habilitation et donc il y aura un
débat parlementaire sur ces lois
d'habilitation et ça ne sera pas un faux
débat
ce sera un vrai débat sur le sur la
politique gouvernementale suite par les
ordonnances et ensuite ça reviendra
devant le parlement dans le processus
habituel vous dire que je suis un adepte
de la procédure d'habilitation et
d'ordre dans ce jeu ne l'est jamais été
je considère aujourd'hui pourquoi je
soutiens ça c'est que sur un certain sur
peu de dossiers mais et dossiers
importants
nous sommes devant une telle urgence
qu'il est nécessaire de prendre des
décisions rapides ce pays souffre de
blocage est ce qu'il n'ya pas justement
un risque de blocage à risque de
mouvements de grève d'un mouvement de
blocage on a vu ce qu'il s'est passé
avec la loi elle comme riz à l'hiver des
français qu'on votait ils ont choisi un
président de la république dont la
caractéristique du programme a été la
clarté que ce soit sur l'europe
que ce soit sur le travail ou sur
d'autres sujets donc qu'il y ait la
configuration qu'on a vu à la
présidentielle avec un deuxième tour
faussé par la présence de l'aide à
l'extrême droite
le deuxième tour il n'a pas été faussé
les français ont fait un choix ils ont
envoyé au deuxième tour emmanuel macron
et marine le pen c'est pas un combat
fossé
c'est la réalité démocratique s'il y a
des manifestations et il y en aura à
partir du moment où elles se déroulent
sans violence
eh bien nous sommes un pays démocratique
et je pense que je suis sûr et
d'ailleurs ça a commencé qu'avant cela
il ya un travail de concertation de
discussions bien sûr avec les
représentants des syndicats qu'il soit
salarié avec les organisations
patronales avec les forces politiques
mais les français ont voté
merci les six dernières parties des
poids de vérité avec orianne mancini qui
nous rejoint tout un échec mais heures
bonsoir oriane car alors on connaît un
jacques mézard vos convictions vos
prises de position parfois fortes
est ce que vous êtes soluble dans le
maquereau nisme d'abord je suis pas un
sucre bon donc j'ai eu aucune intention
d'être dissous bon peut-être au-delà de
ça il a pu paraître curieux que je
soutienne depuis longtemps depuis l'été
dernier emmanuel macron je les fais en
toute conscience
en considérant que notre pays avait
besoin de cet électrochoc de dire aussi
mais finalement que la politique que
j'ai menée sur le terrain et aussi ici
au sénat depuis longtemps c'était aller
dans ce sens parce que vous savez j'ai
toujours été élu avec des voix émanant
de la droite modérée de la gauche
modérée du centre et au sénat je
présidais jusqu'à ce matin un groupe qui
avait la caractéristique et qui a
toujours la caractéristique d'avoir dans
son saint robert hue et emmène groupe
excellent républicain qui depuis ce
matin me succède donc j'ai la ville
gilbert barbier sénateur du jura et je
suis convaincu que ce qu'a voulu faire
emmanuel macron de considérer que dans
ce pays les hommes et les femmes de
bonne volonté non extrémiste voulant
travailler ensemble pour sortir le pays
d'un certain nombre de blocages
eh bien c'était en fait ce que à un peu
un modeste niveau
j'avais essayé de faire dans ma vie
locale et au sénat votre modèle en
politique c'est
georges clemenceau 1 ils ne trompent pas
donc je dis c'est une
c'est une admiration modèle là vous vous
dites de lui qu'il avait un caractère
pas toujours facile des propos parfois
un peu dur et une fougue qui peut
générer des difficultés
est ce que c'est une description qui
pourrait s'appliquer à vous j'étais sûr
qu'il allait y avoir droit
qaraqe le gel voyez c'est vrai léger
mais non je décrivais georges clemenceau
je ne me décrirais pas georges
clemenceau à pour moi avait d'immenses
qualités et à un certain nombre de ces
faux pour qui que je peux peut être
partagé avec eux d'avoir du caractère
est ce un défaut c'est est-ce que c'est
compatible avec la discipline que
demandent les manuels macro et ses
ministres
oui oui parce que on peut vous savez ce
qui caractérise pour moi à emmanuel
macron c'est son intelligence avec
emmanuel macron jeune et je ne peux pas
avoir de difficulté de loyauté je lui
dirai et il le sait toujours ce que je
pense mais je serai un ministre loyal
après lui avoir dit ce que je pense mais
on peut dire les choses sans ensuite
entrer dans des débats médiatiques pour
susciter des conflits
j'ai pas l'intention de susciter des
conflits en tous les cas clemenceau
avait un engagement fort sur un sujet
qui mobilise vous-même depuis toujours
et la laïcité la laïcité
vous êtes très impliqué un veau jacques
mézard dans ces questions de défense de
la laïcité et bruno retailleau et le
président du groupe l'est républicain
ici au sénat écrivait ce week-end dans
le figaro emmanuel macron c'est le
multiculturalisme qui réduit la
communauté nationale à la juxtaposition
de communautés d'origine est ce que vous
êtes toujours à l'aise avec les prises
de position des manuels mâcon sur ce
sujet
et beaucoup d'amitié pour bruno
retailleau mais en matière de laïcité
c'est quand même pas le meilleur modèle
la position d' emmanuel macron elle me
convient qu a dit emmanuel macron sur la
laïcité
j'appliquerai toute la loi de 1905
rien que la loi de 1905 et ça c'est le
cadre qui me convient ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire la liberté religieuse mais
le religieux ne doit pas interférer dans
la sphère publique à partir du moment où
le président de la république le
candidat qu'ils président de la
république pose ce cadre-là ai dit je
m'en tiens ce cadre ça me convient moi
je n'accepte pas le communautarisme
c'est quelque chose qui ait su que j'ai
toujours dit ici au sénat il n'y aura
pas d'entorse à la loi 1905 et aux
grands principes de la laïcité alors il
ya une autre question c'est la
moralisation 1
c'est le premier grand chantier du
quinquennat voulu donc et annoncées hier
par françois bayrou d'ailleurs vous avez
dans le passé jacques mézard et émis de
sérieuses réserves notamment lors du
débat de la loi voulu par françois
hollande après laffaire que ça qu'on va
aller écouter ce que vous disiez le 9
juillet 2013
un ministre un membre du gouvernement
monsieur cahuzac est mis en examen et
l'exécutif semble vouloir détourner
l'attention en tournant le projecteur
vers les parlementaires le projet ce
n'est plus seulement de la transparence
mais du voyeurisme matinée de jésuitisme
allah vous diriez vous la même chose
aujourd'hui sur la moralisation mise en
avant
je tiens à vous rappeler plusieurs
choses parce qu'on peut aussi aborder la
question du cumul des mandats moi aussi
la transparence ne me gêne absolument
pas absolument pas ce que je disais à ce
moment là c'est que la réaction du
gouvernement face à la sphère cahuzac
qui a quand même été quelque chose de
remarquable dans le mauvais sens du
terme
ça a été d'utiliser ce que j'appellerais
la repentance pour autrui
ce qui n'est pas une bonne chose qu'il y
ait des règles fortes et vous savez moi
j'ai auditionné 5 heures le président de
la haute autorité transparence sur le
la mission d enquête que j'ai fait et on
a trouvé des solutions d'ailleurs sur un
certain nombre de dossiers
ça ne me gêne aucunement ce que je
déplore c'est que on est ouvert ce que
j'ai appelé la chasse aux élus dans ce
pays dans ce pays
il y à des élus qui ont failli et là il
faut les sanctionner
ils sont un nombre très minoritaire et
je pense que autant la transparence est
absolument indispensable autant jeter en
pâture les élus comme ça a été fait avec
abondance ce n'est pas une bonne chose
est ce que il ya quand même des
propositions dans cette loi sur la
moralisation de la vie publique qui va
arriver notamment une mesure envisagée
la suppression de la réserve
parlementaire est ce que ça vous est
favorable
ça me paraît alors anecdotique
moi j'ai déjà dit dans la presse locale
il ya plusieurs années que sam était
indifférent compass la réserve
parlementaire dans la dotation des
territoires ruraux
c'est quoi la réserve parlementaire dans
un département comme le mien c'est
150000 euros pour 260 communes
alors quand j'entends quand je lis dans
des médias nationaux que c'est avec ça
qu'on fait du client et du clientélisme
c'est à hurler de rire
par contre si on la supprime dans nos
territoires ruraux qui sont peu peuplées
mois dans le groupe que je présidais jeu
la distribuer de la même manière à tous
les départements
ça veut dire que les territoires des
mots où la démographie est la plus
faible seront sanctionnés de fait par
une baisse de subventions ceci étant
alors on peut en faire ce qu'on veut ça
m'empêchera pas de dormir très bientôt
les cas vous avez tout à l'heure dans
cette émission que bien sûr vous n'allez
pas y monter un conflits éventuels avec
nicolas hulot sur les dossiers agricoles
demain vous n'allez pas alimenter un
conflit avec françois bayrou sur la
moralisation des élus je dirai ce que je
pense à vous dire ce que vous en dirai
que je pense au conseil des ministres
une fois que le braqueur loi sera calé
eh bien je suivrai le gouvernement bien
agréable je suis un planche de jeu de
jean pierre chevènement quand on est
ministre
que disait-il on se soumet où on se
démettrait rapidement de questions très
rapide jacques mézard il nous reste peu
de temps est ce que vous souhaitez à
l'issue des sénatoriales qu'un groupe
des progressistes se constitue ici au
sénat
j'ai eu l'habitude de répondre
directement
je présidais jusqu'à ce matin le groupe
du rassemblement démocratique que l'on
peut considérer comme le groupe
historique de la haute assemblée qui a
été le premier groupe parlementaire
créée en france en 1892 qui a toujours
réuni des femmes et des hommes de
progrès et prix de laïcité et de liberté
avec la liberté d'expression il
appartiendra à ceux sénatrices et
sénateurs
aujourd'hui composant ce groupe de dire
ce qu'il souhaite faire
moi je souhaite que ce groupe continue à
exister parce que c'est un groupe et
d'ailleurs qui est dans la dans la
démarche l'egypte à l'heure de
rassemblement ensuite ceux qui sont
prendrons les décisions et je les
aiderai à l'aï travaillée merci merci
beaucoup ariane merci jacques mézard en
privera donc bien ces grands rendez vous
que vous fixé pour l'agriculture
française dans l'est dans les mois qui
viennent vous n'aurez pas d'été
puisqu'il ya cette grande réunion que
prévu appuyé sur voilà tout ce qu'elle a
pu pour cet été surtout avant même
merci à tous dimanche soir a très vite
on soit